[Music]
welcome back to harbor unboxed today
I've got a quick breaking news story
that I want to cover I don't often do
these on the channel but this one could
be very important for viewers shopping
for an affordable GPU before Christmas
normally it's Intel or Nvidia making
these bad anti consumer decisions but
every now and then the industry underdog
joins in this year's Radeon rx 500
series refresh wasn't exactly met with
open arms by reviewers all consumers but
at least we got slightly faster products
at a slightly lower MSRP even if they
were just factory overclocked to achieve
those extra frames shortly after the
release pricing went haywire thanks to
cryptocurrency mining but you guys know
all about that and that's not really
AMD's fault anyway fast forward to today
basically the end of 2017 and it's fair
to say AMD's GPU division has had a year
to forget however not wanting to end the
year with Vega pricing and availability
all that controversy being the caption
for 2017 they've come up with something
that's actually better or worse
depending on how you look at it meet the
brand-new Radeon rx 560 or is this or
this one the original one I can't tell
and that's pretty much the problem here
to your average consumer there may be no
real way of telling whether you're
buying a new radio RX 560 or an old
Radeon rx 560 that's obviously a big
problem as of today there is now a
second version of the Radeon rx 560
that's appeared online and it does have
slightly different specifications
compared to the original card the new
radio rx 560 ships with 896 stream
processors down from the original 1024
and this is a result of just having 14
compute units enabled whereas the
original has all 16 so that makes the I
suppose new Radeon rx 560 a straight
rebadge of the rx 460 aimday already did
this with the RX 560 d4 the Asian
markets earlier in the year
the RX 560 D was just a rebadged rx 460
but the D made it clear that this was in
some way different to the normal rx 560
in this instance it indicated that this
was a cut-down model however the new
Radeon rx 560 and we'll be saying radio
rx 560 allow this video with just 896
stream processors will also be known as
the Radeon rx 560 why not the rx 555 for
example or why not just stick with the
560 D which we were sort of already
aware of and the people in the Asian
market certainly were I have no idea why
AMD have chosen to do this but does seem
very underhanded and very sneaky sly
just bad jumping over to newegg.com you
can filter search results quite heavily
and under the stream processors tab you
can select either 896 or 1,024 stream
processors selecting 896 stream
processors we get a few models from
assumed power color suits for example
have designated their cut-down rx5 60
cards as evo models which cheer average
consumer really means nothing and I
suppose could be interpreted as being
more special than non Evo models the
cheapest of the cut-down rx 560 models
cost just 125 dollars us and that's the
power hello
red dragon RX 560 and from a consumer
standpoint I'm not sure how to work out
which of the power color rx5 60s have
the full 1024 SPU's and which don't they
don't seem to list how many stream
processors each model has on their own
websites so that makes the issue all the
more confusing
anyway thankfully newegg.com are better
at stating what's what and that's
probably more to save their own bacon at
125 dollars the 896 spu power color RX
560 is fairly cheap but for as little as
five dollars more you can land yourself
a gigabyte RX 560 gaming OC 4g and that
has all 1024 SPU's enabled making it
around say 8 percent faster overall for
me a $5 increase in price so it's quite
shocking to me at least the
AMD thought it would be okay to just
change the RX 560 backs to the RX 460
spec and just brush that change under
the carpet for consumers it's extremely
concerning that there's really no
clearly identifiable Monica to
differentiate between the new and
original models AMD really they seem to
be relying exclusively on board partners
to disclose the final specs of the
aftermarket graphics cards and as we've
just seen in the power color example
it's not really a consumer friendly
approach choosing between two gigabyte
or four gigabytes of vram buffer that
can already be a bit of a challenge for
non enthusiasts adding additional
specifications to the mix that are even
as obviously disclosed as the memory
buffer capacity
well that just further complicates the
hardware selection process it makes it
very difficult for another system
builders performance figures they might
only vary by a few frames in most
instances they will vary by more than a
few frames and others but really that's
hardly the point
this move by AMD further validates my
decision I recommended the GTX 1050 over
the rx 565 months ago now the GTX 1050
can be had for as little as a hundred
and twenty dollars and when compared to
the rx 460 it's just outright faster of
course in video are far from Saints
themselves but that's not the point of
this video this is really a rare and you
consumer move by AMD so I think it's
important we give them a hard time about
it so they don't feel the need to do it
again or at least feel like they could
get away with it if they do get away
with it this time
hmm just finally I have asked AMD for an
official statement and I am yet to hear
from them but I did only ask them that
this morning so they may be putting
something together who knows there's
quite a few news outlets and tech sites
and whatever that are concerned about
this and it's not really a rumor which
is why I'm reporting on it it's not
something that we have changed a spec on
their website and it's a typo or
something like that this is actually
happening there are rx 560 graphics
cards in the wild that you can purchase
that look to be cheap and they may even
end up being okay in terms of value
adjacent to a real rx 560 but that's not
the point
if you don't in your leg and you think
well these are
five sixty that's really cheap I've just
researched this card I know how performs
I'm gonna buy it you're actually buying
an Rx for 60 and that is the problem
here
anyway I'm gonna leave it at that happy
house Steve
I'll see ya next time
[Music]
you